hey everybody i'm stevo and this is
wendy and now i'm gonna walk you through
my guilty pleasures
this is snacked yeah
[Music]
so starting off
i've got something that i eat when i'm
trying to behave myself it's the quest
peanut butter cup it has less than one
gram of sugar per serving so i don't
feel like too much of an [ __ ] when
i'm eating them but the problem is i get
like a whole box and eat them all in one
go
it's really remarkable how delicious
they are given what little sugar's in
there
wow
really
pretty damn good unfortunately a lot of
the time i'm not trying to behave myself
i'm just completely eating like an
[ __ ] and that's when reese's come
into play there's no end to how many of
these i can eat ever since i was a kid
i've loved them
oh and these are like annoying little
ones
not big enough
there's something about the way it's
sweet and a little bit salty
i'm like
i don't know dude it's just magic man
i gotta save him because i know i have a
lot of snacks but dude i can't stop
this next snack
i cannot overstate its importance to me
in my life
you can only get it in england
and it's called
pickled onion monster munch
this stuff is so weird and
so delicious
i'm about to black out right here
you can't compare it to anything it
doesn't even remotely remind me of
anything
guys like i need a few minutes
i made a regular habit when connecting
flights through london
to leave the airport and go and just
wipe out gas stations and convenience
stores
one time i said budget and i played
[Music]
i promise we'll continue soon
i really just kind of blacked out on
that one man
last night i told my girl that i was
doing this and she asked what snacks did
i put on my list i told her that one of
them was safe catch tuna with wishbone
italian dressing
and she said yep that's what i eat every
day almost like every day
[Music]
now they say don't drain the water on
this can i think that's weird i totally
drain the water
and then i replace it with wishbone
italian dressing
and i know there's probably some people
watching this right now saying dude i
thought stevo was vegan and yeah i was
totally militantly vegan for like four
years but then i decided you know what
fish is good for me
so i just put
then
yeah there we go
yeah
a lot of people think i'm weird for
eating tuna out of the can with salad
dressing
i don't get it
breakfast with champions dude
all right
now i shouldn't but i'm gonna count this
as health food too
barbell's caramel and cashew protein bar
20 grams of protein
no added sugar
i don't know how that's possible
because it's so good
well these things are [ __ ] dangerous
man at a certain point i realized that i
was just kind of fat i was like damn i
gotta like reel it in i would try to eat
less i would try to eat better sometimes
like
i yo-yo down and then i yo-yo up and
right now i'm on a major upswing
so
i think we can just go ahead and dive
into the glazed donuts now
what we have here is just pure heaven
can you see that jeez
so [ __ ] good man thank god i brought
my own coffee too
this might be the best glazed donut i've
had in a long time
i'm really enjoying this job
you just can't be an old-school
classic glazed donut
oh
[ __ ]
are we getting close to the end because
i'm starting to like feel shame
all right i kind of don't even want to
admit this but
there was a point when
i sat down with a whole bag of fun-sized
butterfingers
and just crushed the whole thing and
there was so much shame in that and i
got into a food program i reached out to
people i know in recovery and i was like
i need help with food
and clearly i have relapsed so you know
i'm ending on butterfingers
admitting that i'd qualify as a food
addict and sit here doing this is really
dark man
there's something about bunny fingers
that are so delicious that i can deal
with it
you know
i need to back away from the
butterfingers
so
i'm stephen
thank you for watching and come check me
out on tour man you think this was crazy
dude where'd you see my bucket list show
[ __ ]
oh yeah and watch jackass forever in
movie theaters on february 4th
or whenever
[Music]
you